très rapide sur et un chiffre sur le
pourquoi c'est à dire d'où on vient
premier semestre 2021 les pratiques de
piratage et contenu culturels sont best
tendance les pratiques de piratage des
contenus sportifs sont en hausse
tendance avec plus de 3 millions
d'utilisateurs qui chaque mois
effectivement se connectent pour pouvoir
avoir la possibilité de voir des matchs
non pas d'une manière licite à travers
des abonnements à Canal à Bing mais à
travers effectivement toute une galaxie
de site pirate qui leur offre
gratuitement la plupart du temps
effectivement l'accès l'accès au match
le défi que au fond on avait à surmonter
c'était à la fois et c'était assez
difficile en fait et certains d'entre
vous sans doute s'en souviennent lors
des débats de trouver un point
d'équilibre entre d'une part
effectivement la nécessité de pouvoir
instaurer un blocage qui soit efficace
donc rapide puisque voilà le spécificité
des manifestations compétitions
sportives et que la valeur même de la
manifestation de la compétition elle
s'éteint voilà en deux heures pour un
match de foot voilà en tout cas dans le
temps même de la compétition et bien sûr
de devoir respecter la liberté de
communication et le rôle du juge qui
voilà et le garant des libertés
publiques et qui doit intervenir donc
d'une manière j'allais dire fondatrice
dans le dans le dispositif et ce qui est
nouveau ce qui est effectivement n'avait
jamais à ce stade était instauré c'est
de pouvoir concevoir le rôle d'une
autorité administrative en l'occurrence
l'arcome depuis le 1er janvier pour
mettre en oeuvre en réalité d'une
manière dynamique c'est-à-dire dans le
temps dans la durée dans une forme
d'actualisation la décision la décision
du juge alors comment ça se passe ça se
passe voilà j'ai là aussi essayé d'être
le plus concret possible parce que moi
non plus j'ai jamais piraté donc je
parle de ce que je ne connais pas en
réalité
Personne
voilà on part du principe effectivement
qu'on est tous parfaitement profane en
la matière la première étape c'est
effectivement l'étape de la saisine du
juge alors ceux qui peuvent le saisir ce
sont soit les fédérations ou les ligues
ou encore les chaînes de télévision qui
ont acquis des droits exclusifs de
diffusion souvent à prix d'or et donc
qui doivent saisir le juge en pouvant
mettre en avant la preuve à travers des
constat d'huissiers en réalité et des
captations d'écran que ces sites donc
qu'ils doivent viser bien sûr dans le
dans la saisine du juge porte à des
atteins graves et répétés c'est vraiment
le l'exigence de la loi donc à leur
droit et il faut que ces atteins graves
et répétés étaient
occasionné par le contenu d'un site en
ligne dont l'un des objectifs est
principalement la diffusion sous
autorisation de ces compétitions
le juge statut selon une procédure
d'urgence qui est la procédure dite
d'accélérer au fond ou de procédure de
référé et il peut alors prescrire et
c'est très important toute mesure toute
mesure susceptible de faire cesser ses
atteintes envers en réalité toute
personne morale qui est en état de
pouvoir le faire
à ce stade et concrètement le juge n’est
saisi que au fin de notifié au
fournisseur d'accès Internet le blocage
de site mais en réalité le dispositif
législatif est beaucoup plus large et
permettrait d'embrasser d'autres
d'autres acteurs j'en dirai un mot sur
j'allais dire les limites actuelles du
dispositif et les voix éventuelles
d'évolution d'évolution possible donc
l'intervention du juge est suivie par
celle de l'arcom c'est la c'est la
deuxième étape
dès lors que la décision judiciaire est
devenue définitive mais que les ayants
droits sportifs
constatent que en réalité la mesure de
blocage est contournée par l'apparition
de sites qu'on appelle les sites miroirs
en réalité qui permettent l'accès
effectivement à la même compétition
les ayants droits peuvent effectivement
saisir saisir l'air comme sur la base en
réalité à nouveau de constatation
en transmettant les données
d'identification des sites évidemment
dont ils ont constaté qu'ils étaient
illicites puisqu'il permettait là aussi
de pouvoir capter les matchs qui
pourtant faisaient étaient dans le champ
de l'ordonnance de l'ordonnance
judiciaire et nous à l'arcome à travers
la présence d'agents habilités de
l'arcome assermenté donc on a pour
mission d'instruire ces saisines et de
dresser quand on constate effectivement
quasiment que les sites qui ont été mis
en avant par la saisine des ayants
droits sont bien des sites qui soient
diffusent directement soit on l'objectif
c'est à dire dans leur propositions donc
mettre en avant la diffusion prochaine
donc des mêmes compétitions alors nous
sommes effectivement en capacité de
pouvoir notifier au fournisseurs d'accès
Internet le blocage le blocage de de ces
sites de ces sites miroirs le les seuls
qui peuvent agir en la matière c'est à
dire qu'ils peuvent donner en réalité le
top départ
aux fournisseurs d'accès Internet ce
n'est pas le collège donc c'est aussi un
élément qui est un peu dire exceptionnel
c'est soit le président du collège soit
le ou les membres qu'il désignera il a
demandé aux deux magistrats Laurence
pecorivolier qui est donc considéré
accord de cassation et votre serviteur
donc est conseillé de pouvoir
effectivement suivre plus
particulièrement cette cette procédure
et de pouvoir valider les notifications
de blocage aux fournisseurs d'accès
Internet concrètement donc on communique
à ceci une liste de noms de domaine qui
sont les noms de domaine correspondants
et donc à ces services illicites alors
comment le dispositif s'est déployé
depuis donc le 1er janvier on a 9 mois
de neuf mois de recul 10 décisions de
justice donc c'est vraiment la clé de
contact du dispositif obtenu par des
diffuseurs canal et Bing une ligue la
Ligue de football professionnel qui
représentée par Matthieu ficault la
Fédération française de tennis et les
compétitions principalement des
compétitions de football donc
l'Afrique la Coupe d'Afrique des nations
la Ligue 1 et 2 la première ligue le Top
14 ça on passe au rugby et puis des
sports mécaniques et le tennis
le tribunal donc quel tribunal de Paris
compétent pour pour ce type de litige
c'est armé lui-même donc avec
effectivement une magistrate dédiée qui
donc connaît la matière et donc étant
capacité de pouvoir réagir très
rapidement donc
rendent des décisions dans des délais
exceptionnellement courts j'ai été dans
un passé très ancien magistrat je dois
dire que j'ai été effectivement
extrêmement admiratif de la manière dont
les choses se sont passées au niveau
judiciaire mais ça a été effectivement
une une préoccupation du président du
tribunal judiciaire de faire que cette
procédure fonctionne dès sa mise en
place vraiment dans des délais
exceptionnels
à ce moment-là donc le blocage qui a été
ordonné à travers ses 10 décisions
embrasse 350 services et les sites
et dans le même temps c'est à dire dans
celui comme je l'ai dit qui suit
immédiatement en fait la décision
judiciaire parce que les sites miroirs
sont des sites miroirs très réactifs qui
apparaissent pratiquement dans les
heures qui suivent les jours qui suivent
donc dans l'arcome a été saisi par les
mêmes ayants droits d'ailleurs que j'ai
évoqué de 46 îles et à notifié donc
le blocage de plus de 480 noms de
domaine au fournisseur d'accès Internet
alors l'instruction nous-mêmes
évidemment on s'est mis en état comme
l'institution judiciaire parisienne
l'avait fait de pouvoir répondre en
général dans un délai qui est de
quelques jours et ensuite je dois le
dire les mesures de blocage sont
appliquées par les fournisseurs d'accès
dans des délais qui eux-mêmes sont des
délais de quelques heures lorsque
l'arcome leur transfert effectivement
les données de ces noms de domaine des
sites des sites illicites donc ce que
vraiment je dois saluer ici à travers
ces neuf mois c'est la qualité d'un
travail d'équipe c'est-à-dire d'un bout
à l'autre de la chaîne le juge les
ayants droits bien sûr les fournisseurs
d'accès internet je parle en dernier de
l'arcome ont vraiment joué chacun un
rôle majeur dans l'efficacité et les
résultats que que je viens de que je
viens d'évoquer en termes de blocage et
je dois le dire de la part des
fournisseurs d'accès Internet à ce stade
sans j'allais dire mettre en avant les
coûts représentés par la mise en œuvre
de ces de ces blocages voilà alors ce
bilan donc il a abouti voilà parce
qu'au-delà des blocages on s'est
intéressé savoir comment l'audience qui
se dirigeait vers les sites illicites à
réagi
alors il se trouve que donc on a observé
que entre janvier 2021 c'est à dire
premier semestre 2021 et premier
semestre 2022 de moitié l'audience
illicite avec
on est passé donc premier semestre de
l'année dernière à 3 millions 2 de
d'internautes qui en live streaming
avait accès à ces sites illicites par
mois à un million 7 donc des mêmes
internautes qui aujourd'hui
effectivement
accède à ces sites illicites près de la
moitié de ce qui le contenu d'appeler
les lives streamers c'est à dire ces
internautes quand ils sont confrontés au
blocage des sites se détournent de ceci
48%, c'est quand même la moitié
37% 16 donc leur pratique et 15% vont
vers l'offre légale donc et souscrivent
un abonnement à une des chaînes qui
propose les compétitions auxquelles ils
veulent ils veulent accéder pour autant
parce qu'il faut effectivement
s'intéresser aussi au vert à moitié vide
en quelque sorte il reste donc
100% d'internautes qui poursuivent leur
pratique illicites
en utilisant pour certains donc des
moyens de contournement et donc c'est un
peu j'allais dire vers ces pistes là que
je souhaiterais conclure c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire à partir de
ce constat encore une fois très
satisfaisant mais sans doute insuffisant
il faut que à travers une vigilance
accrue on puisse donc je crois atteindre
trois objectifs le premier objectif
c'est de renforcer par le biais d'accord
entre les fournisseurs d'accès Internet
les titulaires des droits sportifs
renforcer la coopération entre eux et
permettent une mise en oeuvre des
mesures de blocage qui s'inscrivent dans
une solution de blocage automatisé
c'est très important car je pense
effectivement que la réactivité du
dispositif peut être serrée deuxième
objectif il faut qu'on améliore les
solutions technologiques de blocage et
travailler aujourd'hui on travaille sur
des blocages DNS c'est-à-dire des noms
de domaine travailler sur le blocage de
par l'adresse IP qui est beaucoup plus
très de la diffusion illicite pour
limiter l'effet des pratiques de
contournement troisième objectif il faut
et la loi nous permet c'est ce que je
disais d'emblée impliquer dans la lutte
contre ce piratage sportif l'ensemble
des intermédiaires techniques de cet
écosystème tel que les fournisseurs de
systèmes de noms de domaine les réseaux
privés virtuels les VPN les services
d'hébergement par exemple l'attefaire
bref tous ceux qui permettent
actuellement à 12% de ces internautes
live streamers qui confronté au blocage
on recouvre à ses moyens techniques de
contournement
DNS al négatif ou VPN qui leur
permettent d'échapper en quelque sorte
aux effets du blocage voilà ce que je
souhaitais rapidement vous donner comme
élément merci Monsieur raffens c'est
très clair je vais passer maintenant la
parole à la des loulous pour qu'elle
nous dise un peu concrètement comment se
passe l'intervention des FAI et est-ce
que vous aussi vous avez
identifié des pistes d'amélioration
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame et messieurs les
sénateurs donc la Fédération Française
des Télécoms que je représente ici et
heureuse d'apporter le témoignage de son
expérience dans la mise en oeuvre de la
loi du 25 octobre 2021 qui est à ce
stade assez unique en Europe les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet agissent
en quelque sorte en tant que prestataire
occasionnel du service public lorsqu'ils
exercent déjà depuis longtemps la police
des contenus pour des raisons d'intérêt
public majeures notamment en matière de
lutte contre la P2 port de graphie
contre les incitations publiques à
commettre des actes terroristes ou
encore les propos haineux nous agissons
aussi en tant que prestataire
occasionnel pour lutter contre la
protection pour protéger des intérêts
légitimes nous agissons donc en tant
qu'auxiliaire de la lutte contre les
jeux illégaux ou la protection des
droits de propriété intellectuelles avec
la dopie depuis longtemps et donc plus
récemment dans la protection des droits
sportifs avec la loi du 25 octobre 2021
la loi qui doit beaucoup être travaux de
votre commission fait de la France un
des pays d'Europe dont l'arsenal
juridique est le plus complet je vous
renvoie à cet effet elle a très longue
et très détaillée étude de
l'Observatoire de l'audiovisuel du
Conseil de l'Europe de 2021 qui contient
des études pays par pays nous avons bien
conscience des intérêts en jeu en ce qui
concerne la protection des droits
sportifs avec l'économie évidemment de
l'audiovisuel mais aussi l'économie des
filières sportives et donc nous sommes
fiers de participer à la protection de
ses droits et nous avons également le
souci de respecter les équilibres
que les parlementaires ont pris soin de
dessiner entre d'une part la protection
des droits fondamentaux avec notamment
la liberté d'expression et de
consultation des sites internet dont
nous sommes aussi légarants en matière
pratique et d'autre part l'innovation
avec le blocage des sites miroirs donc
le mécanisme se déroule en deux étapes
il y a d'abord une décision du juge qui
est rendue sur saisine des ayons droits
au début de chaque compétition de chaque
saison qui demande le blocage de sites
pirate identifiés et qui donne ensuite
le pouvoir à l'arcome d'agir contre de
nouveaux sites les sites miroirs et donc
pendant toute la durée de la compétition
ou de la saison les titulaires de droits
sportifs saisissent à ce moment-là
directement l'arcom pour bloquer des
nouveaux sites les sites miroirs dans
des délais plus brefs
alors quel est notre positionnement
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la loi
nous avons protégé un certain nombre de
retransmission sportive notamment de la
Coupe d'Afrique des nations des Ligue 1
et de football le Top 14 de rugby la
Ligue des Champions Roland-Garros des
Grands Prix de Formule 1 ou de moto ou
encore la première ligue anglaise au
total nous avons bloqué plus de 835 noms
de domaine et nous sommes fiers d'avoir
mesuré
à avoir contribué dans la mesure qui a
été décrite par Denis Rapon à
l'utilisation de sites de streaming
illégal nous le faisons grâce à la bonne
coopération de toutes les acteurs de
tous les acteurs et nous avons
conscience de l'importance d'agir dans
des livres bref puisque toute la valeur
économique est portée dans la première
transmission du flux nous appelons sur
la base de cette première expérience à
une industrialisation du dispositif et
nous rejoignons complètement le vœu de
l'arcome sur ce sujet le législateur a
pris soin de proposer une régulation
moderne qui prévoit que l’arcome élabore
un modèle d'accord pour tous les acteurs
et nous appelons à la mise en oeuvre de
ce modèle d'accord de nos vœux c'est
pour cela que de manière constante et
depuis un an nous avons fait preuve
d'une bonne volonté de coopération en
novembre 2021 nous avons proposé un
cahier des charges qui permettait la
mise en place d'une brique technique
pour récupérer de manière automatiqueée
les listes de sites à bloquer auprès de
l'arcome en début d'année 2022 notamment
en février en juin chaque fois je suis
venu à l'arcom donc en compagnie à des
ayants droits nous avons proposé un
dispositif de coordination des actions
des titulaires de droit les aircoms et
l'opérateur afin de fluidifier le
processus au global et nous proposons
des amendements de manière raisonnable
et constructive au projet d'accord de
l'arcome nous agissons aussi depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi avec
diligence en mobilisant pour l'instant
du personnel habilité y compris lors
d'astreinte et ces personnels habilités
doivent parfois composer avec des
demandes multiples de demandes de
blocage pour des raisons d'intérêt
public majeures et de protection des
droits sportifs pour les seuls blocages
de droits sportifs compte tenu
l'exigence de diligence que je rappelais
que nous respectons les astreintes
nécessitent pour l'instant une personne
qui active le blocage de manière
manuelle un ingénieur réseau et un
ingénieur DNS nous avons également
engagé des investissements spécifiques
sans perspective certaines d'être
compensées et nous acquitons aussi des
honoraires d'avocat à ce jour dans une
dizaine d'instances sans être compensés
non plus ce qui est paradoxal parce
qu'en vertu du principe constitutionnel
de juste rémunération dans tous les
autres domaines dans lesquels nous
agissons en tant que prestataire
occasionnel du service public ou
auxiliaire de la protection des droits
nous sommes en principe compensé du fait
de la loi ou du fait d'accord
neutroposition est guidée par quatre
principes d'abord à l'égalité de
traitement des titulaires de droit
l'efficience et l'efficacité
opérationnelle pour miniser les coûts
d'investissement quel que soit les
personnes qui les prend en charge et les
coûts opérationnels le respect du
principe de proportionnalité
je suis moi-même ancienne juriste je
suis toujours juriste d'ailleurs dans
l'entreprise dans laquelle je travaille
on est juré sans le reste en général et
donc ce principe de proportionnalité il
est au cœur du droit constitutionnel et
européen et il a pour conséquence que
doivent être minimisés les atteintes à
la liberté de consultation des sites
Internet et notamment les surblocages et
enfin nous demandons évidemment la
compensation des coûts nous demandons
pas d'être rémunéré en dégageant un
bénéfice nous demandons simplement de ne
pas travailler un pur perte alors que
nous travaillons pour le compte d'autres
opérateurs privés en tant qu'opérateur
privé pour que chacun y trouve son
compte ce que nous avons proposé dans le
projet d'accord depuis un an c'est
d'aller au-delà un peu de ce que prévoit
le minimum légal de faire mieux pour
tout le monde parce que nous mettons
aussi à la place des autres parties à
l'accord et de nous saisir tous des
opportunités d'un accord donc nous
proposons de simplifier les procédures
en industrialisant en automatisant le
traitement de demande plutôt que de
faire appel à chaque fois à des
personnels habilités pour cela nous
avons besoin du calendrier de
manifestations sportives qui nous sont
donnés d'ailleurs de mieux en mieux nous
avons besoin de formats de fichiers
harmonisés d'une notoriété des blocages
nous nous engageons même à pouvoir
bloquer les sites avec
l'industrialisation en 45 minutes ce qui
est quand même un délai de réaction
extrêmement efficace et nous demandons
simplement la compensation des coûts
donc les enjeux sont de 500.000 euros
d'investissement et de développement
initial dont nous proposons de prendre
en charge la moitié donc de partager
entre les ayants droits et les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet et la
compensation des coopérationnels
courants des blocages de sites donc
150000 euros par an donc nous prenons en
charge la moitié et nous attendons des
ayons droits qu'ils prennent en charge
la moitié nous avons évidemment en
justifié la nature de ses coups je vais
vous en faire grâce ici mais on a quand
même deux étalons de comparaison d'abord
l'enjeu économique des droits sportifs
qui est plus
par an donc je crois que le coût est
quand même raisonnable par rapport aux
gains qui peut être dégagé et aussi le
coup qui avait été chiffré par
l'Inspection générale des finances en
tout indépendance pour l'identification
des pirates au profit de la dopie qui
est de 120.000 euros par an donc ça
revient la même chose pour les
coopérationnels courants si je mets de
côté les coûts d'investissement donc ces
investissements nous les faisons en
régie donc nous appelons nos vœux un
aboutissement prochain des travaux afin
de permettre aux équipes des opérateurs
d'agir de manière plus efficace et plus
automatisée avec un cadre standardisé ce
sera vraiment l'intérêt de tous le
système de blocage manuel actuel et
précaire eu égard à la volumétrie aux
attentes légitimes et importantes des
titulaires de droits je crois que nous
avons prouvé notre efficacité nous
pouvons encore faire un saut qualitatif
donc nous souhaitons nous saisir de
cette opportunité de cet accord qui sera
un pas important nous avons tissé des
relations de confiance je l'espère avec
nos nouveaux interlocuteurs en tout cas
nous y travaillons tous les jours
justement en montrant le succès des
mécanismes de blocage nous espérons que
nous serons deux à vouloir danser le
tango comme on dit souvent à Bruxelles
même s'il est retransmissions de cette
danse qui peut être sportive n'a pas
fait à ce jour l'objet d'une demande de
blocage donc cet accord sera important
il faut il suffira pas à lui seul nous
sommes prêts aussi à étudier à partir du
moment où le cadre est précis le bloc
AJP pour l'instant nous y voyons
beaucoup de difficultés techniques parce
que autant une adresse DNS et univoque
autant les adresses IP il peut y en
avoir un milliard par site et elles sont
réattribuées en permanence donc il y a
des risques de surblocage qu'on a vu en
Autriche nous sommes prêts pour autant à
mener toutes les études nécessaires pour
progresser du blocage DNS vers l'étude
des blocages IP mais pour ça ils font un
cadre très clair on est prêt à discuter
le cahier des charges de l'étude avec
les autres parties et nous avons besoin
d'être sécurisé du point de vue de la
responsabilité s'il y avait des sur
blocage et puis également d'être certain
que
nous serons compensés de nouveaux coups
qui à ce moment-là seraient nécessaire
sachant que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
d'outils sur étagères enfin devenir
Apple la rappeler d'ailleurs que ce soit
avec le blocage DNS ou le blocage IP il
existe des moyens de contournement et
l'accord en lui-même est le travail des
FAI et des ayants droits ne sera pas
suffisant à lui seul pour enrayer les
mécanismes de piratage et les filières
de piratage il faudra aussi travailler
sans doute avec les hébergeurs les
plateformes d'hébergement afin qu'ils
mettent en place des mécaniques de
détection de contenu illicites nous ne
pouvons pas le faire de notre propre
initiative parce que c'est au cœur des
principes concessionnels c'est au cœur
des principaux européens de la directive
e-commerce et du Règlement internet
ouvert mais eux peuvent le faire il
faudrait travailler aussi sans doute
avec les éditeurs de système
d'exploitation afin d'éviter par exemple
IOS 15 permettre le cont des mesures
techniques de protection avec les
éditeurs de moteurs de recherche qui
mettent en place de nouvelles méthodes
de chiffrement les éditeurs de VPN et
puis tous ceux qui commercialisent les
boîtiers IPTV illégaux c'est un travail
de longue haleine et de long terme donc
vous l'avez compris le système actuel de
traitement manuel déblocage et précaires
nous souhaitons aller vers
l'industrialisation nous faisons des
efforts depuis un an pour parvenir à un
accord j'espère que tout le monde se
saisira dès cette opportunité et que
chacun fera preuve d'esprit sportif donc
les FAI que je représente ici et puis
les trois représentants des ayants
droits qui sont ici et puis
au besoin de toute façon nous avons un
arbitre autour de la table je vous
remercie nous allons rester sur merci
Madame nous allons rester sur
l'application de la loi en demandant aux
ayant droit quelle est leur vision de un
an après de de du piratage est-ce que
les données que nous allez chiffrer
monsieur Rapon qui sont à base d'un
sondage en fait est-ce que vous voulez
les constater bien aussi en termes de
d'audience
et est-ce que vous voyez le piratage
évolué je vais peut-être commandé par
donner la parole à Monsieur Saada si
vous le voulez bien merci bonjour
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs Monsieur le
Conseiller madame la Présidente je
tenais à vous remercier pour
l'initiative de cette table ronde je me
souviens en effet avoir été dans cette
salle parmi les gens sollicités il y a
quelques années elle viendra rappeler le
soutien porté de longue date par le
Sénat à ce sujet la lutte contre le
piratage des contenus audiovisuel et
notamment sportif car nous n'oublions
pas que ce qui nous permet de nous
réunir aujourd'hui et de pouvoir vous
dresser devant vous un premier bilan
objectivement positif de la mise en
oeuvre depuis janvier 22 de l'article 3
de la loi de 2021 c'est bien la juste
après mention des enjeux du piratage
sportif par le Parlement et tout
particulièrement par le Sénat qui a
permis d'aboutir à la définition d'un
dispositif concerté proportionné et à
notre sens adapté
si vous en êtes d'accord je vais d'abord
m'adresser à vous en tant que président
de lapse avant de faire un point plus
spécifique pour pour Canal+ et avant de
laisser la parole à Caroline Gento
secrétaire général adjointe de bean
Media Group et de Mathieu Ficot DGA à
LFP qui vous présenteront également leur
propre bilan
pour mémoire nos trois organisations
sont à l'initiative de l'Association
pour la protection des programmes
sportives donc laps créé en 2018 et
réunissant à la fois ayant droit et
diffuseur j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
saluer l'ensemble des autres membres
dont certains sont présents dans la
salle qui sont mobilisés depuis toutes
ces années dans ce combat commun
tout d'abord nous pouvons collectivement
nous satisfaire des premiers mois de la
mise en place du nouveau dispositif issu
de l'article 3 de la loi qui a démontré
une bonne coordination des partis
prenantes et qui permet d'afficher des
premiers résultats concrets comme cela
vient d'être rappelé ce dispositif
introduit d'une manière inédite en droit
français un nouveau moyen de lutter
contre le piratage sportif en complétant
les outils jusqu'à la offert par la loi
nous allons vous expliciter autant que
nos besoins le dispositif de l'article 3
dans sa mécanique les membres de lapse
l'ont mobilisé individuellement mais
notre ambition partagée a permis dès le
mois de janvier nos coordonnées et
d'échanger sur les bonnes pratiques nous
avons appris ensemble à mobiliser au
mieux le nouvel outil d'abord dans la
première étape que constitue l'obtention
d'une décision judiciaire dite
ordonnance cadre sur une compétition
donnée et collée FAI mettent en œuvre
sur la base d'une première liste de
sites à bloquer comme la rappeler ma
voisine la présidente et juriste
puis dans la seconde étape pour mettre à
jour ces mesures de blocage tout au long
de la compétition en intégrant de
nouveaux sites par le biais d'une
saisine de la recommande via un process
défini avec l'autorité et les premiers
résultats de cette mobilisation
collective sont là selon l'arcom et
comme l'a expliqué devenir rabbonne la
moitié des lives streamers confrontés au
blocage ce serait détourner des sites et
des sites dont nous le confirmons la
chute tendance de l'audience décide de
Live Streaming illicite et corroborer
par d'autres analyses et données
notamment celle fournit tout récemment
par l'alpin et par Médiamétrie l'étude
Mediamétrie mesure un écart significatif
d'audience des sites étudier entre avril
2021 avec 2,7 millions d'utilisateurs en
avril 21 unique sur le mois d'avril et
373 minutes utilisateurs uniques en
avril
20227 373 000
je précise que ces chiffres reflètent la
méthodologie appliquée par leurs sources
ici Médiamétrie chacun va pouvoir
revenir dans le détail sur ces résultats
individuels mais nous pouvons d'ores et
déjà nous réjouir collectivement des
premiers effets de l'article 3 nous
devons surtout ne satisfaire de la
coordination de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui en ressort ce bilan
positif et les résultats d'une d'un
alignement des planètes entre la volonté
des titulaires de droit la compréhension
rapide du juge la diligence des
opérateurs télécoms et l'accompagnement
efficace de l'arcom qui a permis
d'obtenir très rapidement les premiers
résultats sur les blocages un
remerciement tout particulier à l'arcom
et évidemment d'abord à devenir Apple
mon expertise et l'engagement nous
accompagne depuis de nombreuses années
ainsi que Madame la conseillère Laurence
Pecot Rivolier Pauline de la selle qui
est ici et Raphaël berger directeur de
la création Arcom pour leur travail
quotidien à nos côtés dans la mise en
place du nouveau dispositif sport un
remerciement également au FAI pour leur
diligence que je confirme dans la mise
en oeuvre des premières mesures de
blocage les discussions sont
constructives dont les moments depuis
plusieurs mois et elle nous donne bonne
espoir d'aboutir rapidement un accord
pour cranter cette collaboration et
aller vers les prochaines étapes nous
tenons là encore à souligner le rôle
précieux que joue l'arcon dans cette
séquence nous devons toutefois rester
prudent malgré la baisse de l'audience
de ces sites illicite le report des
consommateurs
se sont ventilés dans une certaine
mesure vers un contournement des mesures
de blocage DNS mise en place par les FAI
grâce à l'utilisation de DNS alternatif
ou de VPN ou vers un visionnage illégal
de ces contenus en direct sur certaines
plateformes comme Twitter Tik Tok ou
telegram depuis les premiers blocages la
diffusion en direct a considérablement
augmenté sur ses plateformes ou les
délais de fermeture demeurent
insuffisants malgré un début de
collaboration avec elle
surtout dans une plus forte mesure ces
utilisateurs se sont reportés vers la
consommation illégale de l'IPTV comme
l'explicité étude de l'arcom et j'y
reviendrai le pyjamien tout de suite
d'ailleurs le piratage IPTV est en
réalité un nébule un abus de langage il
s'agit d'une utilisation contrefaisante
d'objets légaux à l'instar de boîtier de
smartphone d'ordinateur ou de télévision
connectée ceux-ci sont détournés de leur
usage légal lorsqu'une application
illégale et téléchargée pour donner
accès à des contenus piratés ce mode de
consommation illicite est
particulièrement destructeur de valeur
en effet à la différence des sites de
Life streaming qui piratent les contenus
le piratage
IPTV attaque lui notre modèle même en
vendant des abonnements
et nous avons de quoi nous inquiéter
nous comprenons de l'étude de larkom que
9% des internautes utilisent de l'IPTV
illicite pour regarder les compétitions
sportives ce qui représente 40% des
consommateurs ayant des usages sportifs
illégaux
nous avons pour notre part des éléments
qui viennent confirmer les tendances
exprimées dans l'étude de la com quant
au report de l'usage illicite vers
l'IPTV nous identifions au quotidien une
présence accrue de ces offres illégales
d'abonnement IPTV sur les réseaux
sociaux que nous scanons l'organisme
similar web a suivi l'évolution de
l'audience de certains services IPTV non
nous savons qu'ils sont très utilisés en
France par exemple le service premium au
TT est ainsi passé de moins de 50 000
utilisateurs mensuels en décembre 2021 à
200 000 utilisateurs en septembre 2022
le service ePlay ou iplay et lui passer
de 45 000 utilisateurs en décembre 2021
à 145 000 utilisateurs en septembre 2022
c'est pourquoi nous ne pouvons nous
arrêter au premier signaux positif de la
mise en place de l'article 3 cette
expérience va nous encourager à aller
plus loin pour structurer massifier la
lutte en s'adaptant à ce phénomène
protéiforme qui est le piratage chacun
aura l'occasion de revenir sur les axes
de sa stratégie individuelle nous nous
partageons déjà les mêmes constats et
objectifs
premièrement nous devons orienter nos
actions vers la lutte contre le
préjudice majeur causé par l'IPTV cette
priorisation nous obligera à mobiliser
le second outil technique de lutte
contre le piratage qui lui est
techniquement le plus adapté à savoir le
blocage dit
IP nous savons en effet que pour lutter
contre cette pratique de piratage la
méthode de blocage la plus efficace et
celle du blocage de la source donc de
l'adresse IP c'est d'ailleurs le choix
opéré en Angleterre par la première
ligue premier championnat de football du
monde avec qui nous échangeons et qui
attribue au blocage IP obtenu par voie
judiciaire une baisse extrêmement
significative de la consommation
illégale IPTV
deuxièmement nous allons devoir prendre
en compte l'ensemble de l'écosystème
complexe du piratage nous devons élargir
nos actions au-delà des opérateurs
télécoms dont j'ai rabais le la logique
constructive aux autres intermédiaires
techniques pour que chacun participe à
la mesure de l'impact qu'il peut avoir
pour endiguer le piratage l'effort ne
peut être que collectif face à des
pirates organisés comme des structures
mafieuses ou des cartels de la drogue
l'APS et ses membres sont pleinement
engagés à poursuivre leur entente et
fournir leurs meilleurs efforts pour
continuer à ce combat il ne s'agit pas
d'une simple question de protection
industrielle mais aussi de maintien de
l'écosystème du sport et de sauvegarde
de l'ordre public dans la sphère
numérique à ce titre nous sommes heureux
de pouvoir compter sur le soutien du
législateur et de la com
pour Canal+ et pour que les choses
soient claires j'affirme que le piratage
est le premier concurrent de Canal+ en
France et dans le monde la destruction
de valeur est massive pour un acteur de
paye TV a fortiori dans un modèle
généraliste au présent à la fois sur le
sport le cinéma et l'audiovisuel
Canal+ tire son propre bilan positif de
la mobilisation du niveau dispositif
issu de l'article 3 notamment en termes
de recrutement d'abonnés gros Canal+ a
obtenu 8 ordonnances permettant le
blocage de sites de Live Streaming
illégaux depuis janvier 2022
c'est en fait une est en cours trois
décisions sont désormais inactives
puisque les compétitions sont arrivées à
leur terme il s'agit des saisons passées
du Top 14 de la Ligue des Champions et
de la première ligue 5 décisions sont
actives ou en cours celles sur la moto
GP celle sur la Formule 1 qui sont
actives jusqu'au novembre celles sur les
saisons en cours de la première ligue du
Top 14 et de la Ligue des Champions
au total depuis le début de l'année 2022
Canal+ a obtenu le blocage de 171 sites
par le biais les premières décisions ces
décisions étaient mises à jour pendant
la compétition viennent quarantaine de
saisines d'actualisation que nous
formulons auprès de l'arcom ces
nouvelles saisies n'ont permis au total
le blocage à ce jour de près de 500 noms
de domaines et probablement 600 d'ici à
la fin de l'année outre la baisse
significative de l'audience décide de
live streaming que nous avons appelé
tout à l'heure nous avons surtout pu
identifié les effets sur nos abonnements
l'analyse interne des recrutements
opérée lors de cinq journées phares de
compétitions sportives sur lequel le
groupe a obtenu des ordonnances de
blocage à savoir le Top 14 la Champions
League la Formule 1 la moto GP la
première ligue a permis d'observer une
augmentation de 55% des recrutements sur
ces journées phares par rapport à 2021
il est bien sûr irréaliste d'attribuer
cette croissance du parc abonné
exclusivement aux facteurs de blocage
des sites mais ce dernier a
nécessairement contribué à l'évolution
positive du nombre de recrutements la
concordance calendaire entre les
blocages opérés à quelques heures des
rencontres voire à quelques minutes des
rencontres comme le Mad PSG Real Madrid
ne peut avoir ne peut qu'avoir eu pardon
un impact positif sur la très forte
hausse de recrutement observée nos
perspectives pour l'année 2023 sont
évidemment une massification ce que nous
avons initié en 2022 en prenant en
compte les décisions en cours
d'obtention nous devrions sur l'année
civile 2023 toute compétition confondues
réalisées environ 76 îles comprenant
chacune 15 sites c'est-à-dire un nombre
total de cils bloqués au cours de
l'année 2023 qui devrait dépasser les
1000 sites
à noter que cette projection ne prend
pas en compte le sujet de l'IPTV dont
j'ai parlé
Canal+ doit en effet désormais accélérer
sa stratégie dans la lutte contre l'IPTV
pour ne pas perdre irrémédiablement la
bataille des contenus cette bataille ne
se livre pas entre les plateformes de
SVOD et les acteurs traditionnels comme
on voudrait bien le croire mais plutôt
entre l'ensemble des acteurs légaux et
les pirates qui les pirent ce fléau
pourrait véritablement remettre en
question les modèles de Payet TV en
jouant sur une ambiguïté la difficulté
vient que de nombreux utilisateurs ne
pensent pas être dans l'illégalité car
il paye une forme d'abonnement cela
pourrait s'apparenter très concrètement
à un double maléfique de mycanal
les outils actuels qu'il s'agisse d'une
notice and takedown ou de la loi ou des
blocages DNS ne sont malheureusement pas
assez efficaces pour atteindre
sensiblement le piratage IPTV
l'enjeu n'est pas d'éradiquer le
piratage ne soyons pas dupe la
contrefaçon existe depuis la nuit des
temps mais il s'agit de trouver le point
de sortie viable d'une crise à venir
liée à l'IPTV en perfectionnant un outil
adapté qui puisse le limiter
je rappelle que les acteurs de l'IPTV et
leurs revenus échappent totalement au
pays dans lesquels ils mettent à
disposition leur offre que ce soit
fiscalement ou réglementairement il ne
participant rien au cercle vertueux
liant les droits audiovisuels et
l'économie globale du sport sur un sujet
que le sonat connaît bien ses acteurs ne
sont ni soumis à des obligations
éditoriales ni à des obligations
d'investissement dans la création
donc j'y reviens la solution et je
conclurai là dessus la plus efficace
contre le phénomène complexe de l'IPTV
et je ne nie pas la complexité semble
aujourd'hui être le second outil
technique accessible à savoir le blocage
à l'adresse IP il permet de résoudre
notamment la difficulté d'approche aussi
d'acteur illégal en bloquant l'accès à
la source c'est-à-dire au serveur qui
héberge les flux ou les contenus
proposés par les services IPTV
c'est d'ailleurs le choix opéré par
certains voisins européens tels que la
première ligue j'ai dit qui en tient un
bilan très positif Canal+ est pleinement
conscient des investissements que va
induire la lutte contre l'IPTV illégale
mais c'est un effort auquel le groupe
consentira pour sauvegarder son modèle
de développement ainsi que la valeur
créée sur le territoire que ce soit pour
le sport ou les autres contenus c'est un
impératif industriel mais surtout
collectif pour préserver les écosystèmes
et politiques publiques touchée par ses
pratiques il est cité dangereuses
après l'exposé de mes collègues je me
tiens naturellement à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions merci
encore de votre suivi de votre écoute et
surtout pour votre mobilisation sur ce
sujet essentiel merci
le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs merci de nous
recevoir autour de cette table ronde
c'est l'occasion également pour BeIn
Sport de remercier l'engagement du Sénat
à nos côtés dans la lutte contre le
piratage des contenus sportifs et plus
particulièrement l'engagement résolu
constant de monsieur le sénateur Michel
Savin du côté de BeIn Sport nous
mesurons le chemin incroyable que nous
avons parcouru depuis 2017 et les
premières initiatives parlementaires et
aujourd'hui 5 ans après ses premières
initiatives nous avons rempli une partie
des objectifs que nous nous étions fixés
via l'adoption de cette loi en octobre
dernier le Sénat nous invite aujourd'hui
à dresser un bilan et ce bilan et comme
Monsieur Rapon et Monsieur Saada voulons
dire extrêmement positif toutefois de
nouveau défi nous attend bien évidemment
dans la lutte incessante contre le vol
que constitue les piratage s'agissant du
bilan que BeIn Sport pourrait dresser je
vous quelques bein sports ne diffuse que
des contenus sportifs premium nous avons
initié notre première action de moi
après l'adoption de la loi c'est à dire
en janvier au fin de protéger la coupe
la Coupe d'Afrique des nations
nous avons obtenu et c'était très
important une décision très rapide c'est
à dire dans les trois jours
et puis nous avons par ailleurs lancé
deux autres décisions pour la protection
de la Ligue des Champions et pour Will
blonden actuellement nous préparons bien
évidemment notre dossier en vue de
protéger la Coupe du monde dont on a pu
dont on mesure d'ores et déjà le fléau
que pourrait être le piratage sur un
événement de cette importance
on a constaté comme l'a dit Monsieur
Rapon et Monsieur Saada une baisse de
l'audience pirate les audiences UCL ont
été divisées l'audience pirate des
matchs de Champions League a été divisé
par 4
et nous tirons donc trois enseignements
de cette première phase premièrement la
loi fonctionne extrêmement bien
puisqu'elle fonctionne tant pour des
compétitions qui se déroulent sur toute
la durée de la saison c'est-à-dire neuf
mois que sur des durées extrêmement
courtes comme bulles donne ou Roland
Garros dont je vous rappelle la durée
est de 15 jours donc ça c'était ça
faisait partie d'un point
d'interrogation et nous sommes très
satisfaits de voir que justement elle
s'applique sur des événements courts et
notamment sur les événements tels que la
Coupe du monde que dont je vous ai parlé
et en troisième enseignement c'est
l'obtention de ce succès bien évidemment
passe par une mobilisation forte des
moyens tant humain que financiers donc
plus pour vous rappeler en amont
les ayants droits sont censés rapporter
la preuve que nous subissons des
atteintes graves et répétées
comment dire en matière de de diffusion
de contenu sportifs et donc nous sommes
tenus à apporter des preuves constantes
pour que le juge puisse rendre sa
décision donc ça veut dire que nous
procédons à de nombreux constats nous
passons par des huissiers enfin c'est
une constitution du dossier en vue de
passer devant le juge qui est
extrêmement lourde
après vous avez effectivement en aval de
la décision les saisines que nous
faisons auprès de la com qui nécessitent
également que l'on continue de dresser
des constats tous les jours afin de
pouvoir actualiser la liste des sites
que nous avions identifiés en première
instance et qui permettra à l'arcom de
pouvoir procéder au blocage successifs
donc tout ça pour vous dire que la lutte
contre le piratage du point de vue des
ayants droits est extrêmement
coûteux non seulement moyen dommage
comme on l'a dit subi par par
l'industrie l'écosystème du sport mais
c'est plus contre les piratage
occasionne de nombreux frais et coûts
qui sont déjà supportés par les
télédiffuseurs et par les ayants droits
pour pouvoir obtenir la protection de
leur contenu ces investissements ce
chiffre en millions en tout cas pour la
société bean Media Group à l'échelle des
pays sur lesquels nous diffusons des
contenus premium
donc afin de clore cette partie
consacrée au premier bilan je dirais
pour la première fois que dans la longue
histoire de la lutte contre le piratage
les titulaires de droits peuvent dire
nous avons un coup d'avance en cette
année 2021 mais comme on vous l'a dit il
faut s'adapter et nous savons que le
piratage a un caractère protéiforme et
que nous devons adapter les outils juste
pour clarifier et apporter quelques
précisions par rapport aux précédentes
interventions
l'article 3 tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
conçu permet justement cette adaptation
il ne s'adresse pas forcément au blocage
DNS ou
IP il est extrêmement large puisqu'il
vise toute mesure appropriée à lutter
contre la mise à disposition de contenu
illicites donc ça veut dire que
on avait déjà anticipé que il fallait
procéder au blocage
IP et que le DNS ne serait pas
comment dire suffisant pour pouvoir
répondre à cette problématique donc le
DNS c'est une on va dire la plus simple
et le l'IP était bien évidemment dans
l'esprit de chacun d'entre nous autour
de cette table pour que le dispositif
soit efficace
bien évidemment il y aura d'autres de
même cet article n'a pas vocation à
s'adresser uniquement aux fournisseurs
d'accès Internet il s'adresse à toute
partenaire de la chaîne du piratage pas
partenaire mais à toute opérateur qui
peut nous aider à lutter contre le
piratage dans le domaine technique à
savoir on l'a vu on a vu les hébergeurs
les moteurs de recherche les Claude fer
les réseaux sociaux etc
sans revenir donc sur la croissance de
l'IPTV illégale on souhaitait également
faire un focus sur sur le fait que le
piratage on l'a vu un petit peu via
monsieur Saada comment dire derrière le
piratage on a affaire à des gens
extrêmement bien organisés
on peut parler de mafia et il y a des
études très intéressantes qui ont été
publiées récemment notamment celle de la
PA qui est un organisme européen pour la
protection des contenus audiovisuels qui
montrent que dans les 61 71 secondes qui
suivent un clic sur un site pirate un
consommateur est confronté au risque de
perte d'identité de vol d'information et
d'identification et de demande de rançon
les risques de virus sont encore plus
élevés pour les consommateurs qui
accèdent à des contenus piratés via des
applications avant avec 57% de chances
que celle-ci contiennent des logiciels
malveillants intégrés
ainsi le piratage ne s'arrête pas
seulement à la protection des ayants
droits et des diffuseurs mais également
à la protection de tout à chacun et même
des citoyens qui naviguent sur Internet
ainsi pour améliorer on est persuadé que
pour améliorer la protection de ce
dispositif le blocage IP comme on l'a
déjà soulevé sera techniquement beaucoup
plus efficace et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les membres de lapse appelent
de leurs vœux la mise en place par les
FAI de ce blocage rappelons que ce
blocage IP est déjà mis en place dans un
grand nombre de pays européens on l'a vu
depuis 5 ans au Royaume-Uni sans
surblocage aucun bloc sur blocage n'a
été constaté c'est également le cas en
Italie c'est également le cas au
Portugal donc ce ne serait pas une
innovation que le blocage IP soit mis en
place en France
évidemment le blocage l'automatisation
et l'industrialisation de ces systèmes
va nécessiter une collaboration encore
plus étroite avec les services de
l'arcom afin que les délais de réaction
d'intervention souhaitent encore plus
réduits et calées sur la protection du
contenu juste je sais pas si on l'a
mentionné dans le cas des interventions
précédentes mais le blocage IP ça
consiste juste à bloquer le signal du
site uniquement pendant la durée du
match ou de la durée de la compétition
ce qui fait que vous avez un écran noir
qui est limité à 90 minutes s'agissant
d'un match de football ce qui fait que
on pense que c'est une mesure qui est
proportionnée par rapport au principe
dont on a évoqué tout à l'heure le
principe de proportionnalité et limite
les risques de surblocage puisque on
aura un blocage limité dans le temps à
90 minutes
pour enchaîner rapidement sur sur la
suite et
ce sur quoi l'APSE se tient toujours
enfin est toujours en alerte et il
travaille et travaille ardemment sur les
autres moyens pour lutter contre le
piratage évidemment donc nous avons
l'article 3 il y a la transposition de
la directive sur le droit d'auteur qui
nous permet d'agir efficacement sur les
plateformes de partage comme YouTube et
Facebook mais on l'a cité il y a
d'autres acteurs qui sont susceptibles
de nous aider ce sont bien évidemment
les hébergeurs techniques pour lequel on
ne souhaite pas du tout modifier la
lceen mais on souhaiterait mettre en
place un retrait immédiat ou à tout le
moins dans les 30 minutes c'est à dire
un engagement que les hébergeurs une
fois qu'ils sont notifiés procèdent à la
coupure du contenu illégal et c'est dans
ce sens que le call to action récemment
lancé à Bruxelles par centaines de
titulaires de droits a été
fait visant à palier si vous voulez
lacunes qu'il y a dans le digital
service actes qui a été comme vous le
savez
voter récemment par la par la Commission
autre obligation sur lequel on pourrait
également s'attacher et concentrer nos
efforts les obligations de traçabilité
la fameuse New York customer New York
business COS summer qui permet
d'identifier les entreprises qui opèrent
sur Internet ces obligations pourraient
être renforcées en effet le DSA
aujourd'hui n'a prévu cette obligation
que pour les places de marché et là
encore c'est une occasion pour nous
manquer de mettre en place un Internet
Plus Sûr pourquoi car dans les faits les
pirates ne peuvent pas mettre leurs
services en ligne sans un nom de domaine
sans être hébergé ou sans service de
publicité ou de paiement ce sont donc
tous les fournisseurs de ses services
qui devraient avoir le devoir d'empêcher
l'accès à leurs services aux entreprises
qui refusent de se conformer aux règles
d'identification
et de telles dispositions ne viendraient
en aucune façon endommager notre article
3 pour lequel nous sommes réunis
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
donc une fois encore nous souhaitons
remercier le Sénat pour son engagement
nous souhaitons et nous espérons que
vous resterez à nos côtés pour suivre
les débats et notamment
l'automatisation l'industrialisation et
l'amélioration des process que nous
allons tenter de mettre en place afin de
rendre le dispositif encore plus
efficient et et voilà on nous espérons
vous avoir à nos côtés encore pour
longtemps merci beaucoup merci madame
monsieur Picot pour la Ligue de football
professionnel
que vous portez à ces sujets je vais
vous demander de bien vouloir m'excuser
si j'enfonce quelques portes ouvertes
mais en avant propos je voudrais
rappeler un certain nombre de choses la
première c'est qu'évidemment le football
et le contenu le plus le plus piraté au
monde et représente auprès de 75% des
contenus sportifs piratés mais je crois
que cette menace ne doit pas être
circonscrite au seul football
professionnel et on voulait rappeler que
que cette menace qui est
plus imminente puisqu'elle est déjà
passée elle est gigantesque pour
l'industrie du sport mais également pour
tous l'écosystème je ne reviendrai pas
sur la théorie économique du
ruissellement mais ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que tout le monde est
concerné pas que le football
professionnel pas que le football
amateur pas que le sport amateur mais
également un tout tous les acteurs
économiques
sur le territoire
j'ai été aussi très sensible aux propos
de de même bientôt et du président
salada lorsqu'il parle et c'est une
réalité ce n'est pas pour être
politiquement correct ou attirer votre
attention sur les risques encourus par
tous les consommateurs et les
internautes qui sont sur ces sites les
risques encourus de détournement de
données personnelles de de risques
diverses et variés lors dépend est une
réalité et ne doit pas être sous-estimée
et enfin et pour moi je à titre
personnel je crois que c'est le plus
grave c'est que l'ensemble de ces sommes
finalement échappe à tout contrôle à
tous mécanismes de solidarité sociétale
à tout un pot et viennent alimenter des
réseaux et aujourd'hui on les appelle
criminels mafieux drogue c'est vraiment
très flou mais mais très inquiétant et
on sait que toutes ces sommes qui
représentent des milliards d'euros
viennent renforcer des activités
criminelles illégales qui qui encore une
fois échappe à tout contrôle
je vais faire très vite sur les actions
de la LFP je suis évidemment très très
positif sur les résultats de ce
dispositif ça nous a permis depuis plus
d'un an pour vous donner un ordre d'idée
de bloquer 410 000 liens de Live
Streaming tant sur le direct sur les
highlights
et près 300 000 référencements sur
Google ou Bing des moteurs de recherche
extrêmement connus depuis un an
évidemment on a aussi une mission de
surveillance de tous les systèmes d'IPTV
et on sait que sur la saison dernière on
a à peu près 1000 serveurs iptvido qui
ont été qui ont été identifiés plus de
4000 chaînes illégales qui sont
monitorées et juste qu'on parle de liptv
et on vous en a beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui
on a sur un dernier match de de Ligue 1
vu que 300 000 personne était en
connectée un soir de match sur un seul
service IPTV
toutes ces actions là elle n'aurait
évidemment pas été possible sans le
principe de l'ordonnance dynamique
et c'est vrai que je profitais de votre
accueil pour bien sûr remercier la
représentation nationale et le Sénat
mais également vous dire que les
principes de saisine judiciaire de
débats contradictoires d'ordonnance
prononcée par le juge évidemment on les
accepte avec grand plaisir d'autant plus
qu'elles sont dégages nécessaires à un
état de droit mais qu'elle nous semble
représenter au final un dispositif
extrêmement efficace qui nous permet
nous-mêmes diffuseur et ayant droit de
de lutter contre ce fléau
je vais faire très vite on a parlé des
mesures de blocage DNS un déniablement
et comme le confirme la reconnu dans sa
dernière étude elles ont porté
ses efforts ont porté leurs fruits de
plus en plus d'internautes sont
effectivement confrontés à des mesures
de blocage sur des sitiers légaux mais
comme le président Saada a rappelé on en
perçoit aujourd'hui les limites c'est un
constat je pense que ici ce n'est pas le
forum pour donner quelques publicités à
tous les détails et solutions de
contournement mais c'est une réalité le
blocage DNS est un dispositif qui a fait
ses preuves et qui grâce à
l'automatisation qu'on appelle aussi de
nos vœux et Madame Belliot je vous en
remercie j'espère qu'on ira très vite
sur ce sujet parce que il continuera à
faire à faire ses preuves mais
aujourd'hui sans dispositif de blocage
IP et j'aimerais vraiment réinsister
encore une fois tous les efforts que
nous avons tous fait depuis des années
risquerait de se révéler 20 dans les
prochains mois
sur l'IPTV je vais passer très très
rapidement parce qu'on en a beaucoup
parlé je veux juste rappeler que la
première ligue est une référence à de
nombreux égards pour la Ligue 1 puisque
c'est une ligne référence en termes de
de valeurs et également le Royaume-Uni
sur un certain nombre de dispositifs et
que c'est pour nous une évidence que la
première ligue a fait du blocage IP la
pierre angulaire de son combat puisque
les blocages IP en première ligue
représentent 90% des actions y compris
pendant les du match en direct donc je
veux pas dire qu'on veut copier les
Britanniques d'une façon systématique
mais il faut qu'on prenne en compte et
qu'on en fasse le constat que c'est une
réalité chez eux et que c'est déjà une
réalité chez nous et
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que c'est pas
pour en faire plaisir monsieur raponne
mais c'est vrai que je tiens à louer ici
les efforts de la com et notamment votre
ténacité pour qu'un accord équilibré
soit conclu entre la Fédération
Française de l'école et lapse
aujourd'hui pour notre part je ne
pourrais parler qu'au nom de la LFP nous
voulons juste nous comporter de façon
pragmatique on doit être à la hauteur
des enjeux on est évidemment prêt à
contribuer significativement au coût
associé c'était aussi une des raisons au
sein de l'APSE qui a pris un petit peu
de temps pour répondre à la Fédération
française des com c'est que les membres
de lapse s'entendent sur une juste
répartition de des coûts donc merci de
votre écoute je voulais juste vous dire
qu'on est dans une courte contre la
montre vraiment
je ne parle pas du fait que la LFP va
lancer en 2023 un appel d'offres qui va
être extrêmement structurant non pas
pour l'économie du football
professionnel mais pour l'économie du
football et du sport dans son ensemble
vous avez tous suivi les derniers
j'allais dire les dernières turbulences
qui ont qui ont touché la Ligue et son
écosystème l'entrée de CVC les ambitions
de la Ligue le besoin effectivement
d'être compétitif au niveau européen
et donc les enjeux seront forts la Ligue
comme tout ayant droit doit une
jouissance paisible de ses droits à ses
diffuseurs qu'ils soient Canal+ bein ou
tout nouvel entrant et il y a un réel
questionnement et que je trouve
extrêmement légitime de la part de ces
derniers sur la capacité de l'ayant
droit qu'est la Ligue A garantir cette
jouissance paisible et
je ne voudrais pas nous nous
souhaiterions pas que à l'issue d'un
appel d'offres les montants attendus ou
les moments MONT raisonnable ça veut
rien dire mais qu'en tout cas
l'optimisation nécessaire de nos droits
ne soient pas en rendez-vous à cause du
risque de piratage et de normalement
l'appréciation des diffuseurs de dire
que le produit va finalement il vaut
moins cher parce que
président Saïda l'a rappelé aujourd'hui
je crois que le plus grand concurrent de
Canal+ va c'est le piratage
donc on se doit d'être à la hauteur de
de cet enjeu et j'espère pouvoir compter
sur la coopération en tout cas nous on
sera présent au rendez-vous nos
interlocuteurs pour avoir des modules de
blocage IP et dans des délais notamment
pendant le déroulé des rencontres donc
pour terminer sur la question de la
diffusion gratuite ou en clair je je ne
crois pas que la diffusion d'un match
par journée de championnat soit la
solution je prends tout à fait le point
que notamment dans les stades vous avez
des catégories de place à des tarifs
extrêmement différents qui permettent
d'adresser des populations tout à fait
différentes et où les
plus riches d'entre nous peuvent aller
en loge et les plus modestes peuvent
aller regarder un match en catégorie 3
il est vrai que en matière télévisée ou
de retransmission ou d'accès à des
programmes via un méthode
médias c'est tout à fait impossible
pour autant
encore une fois notre rôle de maximiser
les revenus c'est pour rendre nos clubs
les plus compétitifs possibles
[Musique]